so leute bevor das video losgeht wollte
ich noch kurz das sagen und zwar habe
ich irgendwann diesen kommentar gelesen
dass ich mich doch mal von einer
büroklammer hoch tauschen soll ich weiß
vorgestern in österreich auf einen
zuschauer treffen und hab mir spontan
gedacht du könntest ja hier einfach mal
mit dem projekt anfangen ich habe von
vielen leuten gehört das ist eigentlich
viel schwieriger ist als man denkt die
meisten leute sind eher nicht bereit
etwas zu tauschen und ich habe vor
daraus eine kleine video reihe zu machen
dass ungefähr so jede woche ein neuer
park kommt weil es ist ein unglaublich
langer weg von einer büroklammer zum
beispiel zu einem handy oder so ich habe
mir das auch viel leichter vorgestellt
ich habe mir nur allerdings gedacht und
jetzt schon mal gut rein zu kommen
vielleicht sind meine zuschauer eher
bereit was zu tauschen als irgendwelche
passanten die man fragt deswegen wünsche
euch viel spaß mit dem video
ich habe es bestmöglich kommentiert und
aufgenommen und habe innerhalb von
zweieinhalb stunden ist von der
büroklammer zu einem gegenstand
geschafft der wirklich so 20 euro kostet
das natürlich jetzt nix mega krasses
aber es folgen weitere parks im darauf
bock habt schreibe es in die kommentare
und rasten nach oben da dann sehe ich
das ja am besten gibt einfach ein daumen
nach oben dann gibt es nichts woche
schon nächsten part und auf der straße
zum beispiel in köln weiß ich noch
schnell sagen wollte ich bin im video
extrem müde ich habe nur drei oder vier
stunden geschlafen und dann direkt den
flug nach österreich nimmt es mir nicht
übel ich finde das sieht man ein
bisschen und jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video
[Musik]
hey leute was geht da vor herzlich
willkommen bei armen video ich bin heute
österreich mit auf jeden fall ist sie
heute die video kommt das ist zuschauer
treffen wurden eingeladen und heute
morgen aus köln hingeflogen ich hoffe
ihr versteht mich gut weil hier ist es
relativ laut ich habe mir für heute aber
was cooles überlegt auf jeden fall habe
ich letztens einen kommentare kommen
unter irgendwo ein video von mir der ist
wirklich explodiert sein was man so von
zwei ich weiß ja über das projekt das
kommt eigentlich aus
in amerika haben das schon öfter leute
gemacht auf youtube habe ich noch gar
nicht gesehen
ihr habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch schon
am titel gelesen wir versuchen heute
eine büroklammer hoch zu tauschen würde
die das nicht kennen das hört sich erst
mal dumm an aber ich habe eine
büroklammer dabei was mal kurz mal so
in deiner hose greifen hier mit pilzes
auf jeden fall haben wir hier diese
büroklammer ist halt gar keine typische
büroklammer sondern wirklich eine
hightech büroklammer und ich war so wie
heute hoch zu tauschen hier sind ja
hoffentlich viele zuschauer von mir und
mal sehen was die mir so geben natürlich
werde ich dann auch noch versuchen hier
ist so eine messe echt aber obwohl ich
doch die regel man darf nicht gegen geld
tauschen es gibt es ein paar einfache
regeln ist erklärt die mal kurz man darf
immer nur einmal mit irgendeiner person
tauschen also nicht auch darf man darf
kein geld tauschen und ich glaube das
war es eigentlich auch schon hier ist
auf jeden fall im rahmen dieser video
kann auf so eine messe
und hier sind einige leute unterwegs und
mal gucken wann ich das erste handy
bekommt also wir sehen uns dann gleich
ein schlimmer gespannt das dann ein haus
bekommt und das sogar ein team kinder zu
machen
so würden wir haben jetzt hier das video
ich bin mal gespannt was sich aus neben
ding machen kann so leute bevor es hier
weiter geht habe ich mir dachte ich
kommentiere das einfach so ein bisschen
nach weil es manchmal mit dem sound ein
bisschen schwierig war da hat immer
jemand gesungen im hintergrund und damit
ihr den besser folgen können was ich so
getauscht habe kommentiert das ist
einfach ein bisschen im hintergrund
let's go
ja
also ich das erste wahl sein corny gegen
die büroklammer hat jemand sofort
getauscht dann habe ich das coni gegen
chips getauscht und ja man vorher
gemacht
die hatten haben wir zum tauschen das
wollte ich aber nicht dann habe ich
allerdings diesen
[Musik]
jetzt aber was dann habe ich irgendwann
eine wasserflasche bekommen die habe ich
nicht mit aufgenommen die habe ich dann
aber gegen schleim getauscht ich habe
sie eine eintrittskarte für morgen
bekommen gegen den schleim danke dieses
10 eur 40 wird die wollten allerdings
fast niemand haben und dann habe ich
einen england studentin dass du denn
dort habe ich dann irgendwann gegen
diesen extrem geil ein schlüsselanhänger
getauscht wir müssen jetzt mal kurz
stopp machen weil ich glaube das war ein
fehler den danach weiter zu tauschen
weil das ding war echt mega geil
das wollte eigentlich jeder haben nur
ich hab's dann blöderweise gegen ein
maßband getauscht warum auch immer und
das maß an wollte dann niemand mehr
haben
so würde ich das gerade das maßband
gegen die mülltonne
gegen die methode tauschen können aber
in diesem fall war ich es halt nicht
weil ich glaube das was man isst mehr
wirklich übel
der grund darin wenn ihr meinen dass
alex karten fehler gemacht
ich habe sie noch nie irgendwo her
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
wir haben euch das mal
[Musik]
euro
optimal mit der einige darstellen kostet
19 euro
ja auf jeden fall das wollte ich mal
kurz nach gucken wir haben hier wirklich
so mag es wenn dafür ungefähr fünf bis
zehn euro die power bank die ich dann
bekommen habe müsste ungefähr warte man
ja so eine hier gewesen sein für gut 16
99 gar nicht mal schlecht
ich habe es gerade noch ein kleines
angebot bekommen und zwar habe ich ja
die power bringt das waren das ziemlich
schwierige entscheidungen sich immer für
das richtige zu entscheiden die hälfte
hat gar nicht verstanden was ich
überhaupt möchte wenn ich so gesagt hat
ihr habt ihr vielleicht irgendwas zu
tauschen kam so kriege ich noch ein foto
auch die power bank wurde mir gesagt du
hast du 10 10 euro um diese wm viele
hedge-fonds ich finde wenn sie bloss
sechs und acht muss auch gülle von
sportarten zu boden das mache ich jetzt
einfach mal ein phone 7 und 8 plus geht
genauso wie vor auch warte mal sieben ja
alles klar
danke dir also leute ich habe jetzt
diese handy hülle
hier ist ja heute messegelände auch mit
hier messen so ist auf jeden fall
einiges los hier das problem ist jetzt
nur wir haben auch noch eine halbe
stunde dann fliegt unser flieger zurück
und ich schaue jetzt mal ob ich noch
irgendwas besseres für diese handys
aber ist ja schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht ich hab da noch drei oder vier
leute auf der messe gefragt die meisten
hatten entweder gar keinen bock darauf
oder nichts wirklich dabei was hat man
auf einer messe auch groß dabei und dann
muss ich auch schon weiter ins flugzeug
deswegen war das projekt eigentlich hier
schon zu ende ihr seht es auch in
kleinen block aber wie gesagt wir machen
nächste woche auf jeden fall weiter dann
am start mit der handy jetzt für 20 euro
die ich bekommen wir also freut euch auf
jeden fall auf das video was dann kommen
wird und jetzt viel spaß noch mit den
letzten 10
so leute wir sind jetzt so weit fertig
hier auf der video konnte in klagenfurt
ist eigentlich echt schön ich war vorher
noch nie hier aber
ich habe es jetzt ich sage mal so in
drei stunden von der büroklammer sondern
handy hülle geschafft die wollen den
wert von 15 20 euro hat bikini bottom a4
finde ich ein ganz lustig natürlich
hätte ich mir das leichter vorgestellt
wir schauen ob ich noch weitermache wir
fahren jetzt erst mal das essen war auch
mehr anstrengen wir sind heute um vier
uhr aufgestanden
du bist gar nicht abgestimmt also wir
sehen uns irgendwann gleich ich habe
keine ahnung
und ich habe gerade baum hängen werke
tauscht es bräuchte man das so es
bräuchte ich einfach die die bauern
bringen und ich hab ich mir in die hölle
getaucht sein handy ist leer und mainz
hat nur noch drei
das
zu lassen
ich traue mich nicht der beste ich habe
schon kaputt machen dann kann ich mach
das jetzt so danke fürs film sowie
wagenrad noch am wörthersee wirklich
sehr schön sehr klares wasser habe ich
selten gesehen dass es so klar es geht
es zurück zum flughafen und zurück nach
frankfurt und dann würde im zug nach
köln ist nämlich noch mit in den block
und dann wenn ich glaube ich das video
oder wollen sie was meine power bankhaus
glaube das waren 1
ach nee ich habe ein handy hülle war auf
jeden fall sehr schön hier auf der video
kommen wahrscheinlich wieder nach wien
wien wird abriss freunde ich mich was
sie gesagt vorne da hinten einsteigen
soll jetzt geht es zurück mit austrian
airlines
das linke seite
[Musik]